Tesla's all-electric automobiles have
made a big splash in the media of course
and in the marketplace since they were
introduced three years ago but the
brand's Model S sedan it has been much
more statistically popular with male
buyers than it has been with female
buyers and the company is now rolling
out its first SUV it's called the Model
X and it claims the car was designed to
appeal specifically to female purchasers
all right Matt Miller so they seem to be
basing this on as you just telling me
during the break only 13% of the initial
buyers of Model S were Whitmer women and
you know more than 50% of car buying
decisions are made by women so I thought
it was interesting that so few took to
the Model S at first yeah and then Tesla
says they had a focus group in Palo Alto
in which they brought women in to ask
them things like what was the most
important and it comes out that safety
and specifically having that third seat
for children and for extra storage was
much higher list yes higher than
performance of the automobiles they want
liability safety and that extra room and
I'm assuming that for men those things
don't top the list maybe reliability
right but safety isn't something that
men generally are as concerned about and
certainly not the third row 85 grand I
think is the sort of about price that's
that's what they say and maybe this one
will stick closer to that but if you've
ever Specht out a Model S wrong in their
configurator which I've done a hundred
times I'm sure you have as well you can
never get below a hundred thousand
dollars so 100 hundred grand for this
SUV I'm thinking once you put all the
bells and whistles of it now that's from
the perspective of a male buyer maybe
it's different when a female I'm just
saying about 85 because you gotta have
the competition area and what does it
have like 300 the Model S has a third
row as well not a lot of people know
this but you can seat seven people in a
Model S and my buddy Hans Humes has done
that on numerous occasions for long
trips to Vermont or something so there
is that capacity but it's just not as
spacious as the Model X apparently is
a very spacious interior right and also
because of the way that it's designed
the electric drivetrain is so much lower
in the car than it would be in a regular
automobile that the center of gravity
goes lower so that means you don't have
that big sway when you're driving an SUV
on that's right and that's the that's
the beauty of the s2 so it has the
performance maybe and the space right